all right what up guys welcome to the
just part oh gosh my hairs freezing
welcome to the just pearly things
YouTube channel
today I
I'm gonna be talking to you about a
decision that I've made sort of guys my
mom doesn't know yet so don't don't tell
her don't tell her okay if I'm driving
I'm just driving in my parents backyard
so
so okay I decided where I want to move
now you're thinking Hannah you've been
contemplating for this for months going
back and forth well I decided I'm gonna
coach my sister's basketball team right
hold up I'm gonna show you guys where
we're going and the thing is about
coaching my sister's basketball team is
I have to be in Chicago
and I was like well I need to coach her
because she keeps getting bullied all
right she she keeps getting bullied in
the paint these my my sister's skinny
she's skinnier than me my skinniest
sister okay and the she's a center and
these fat chicks just keep these mini
whales they're in high school so they're
not whales yet but y'all know how it is
if you play basketball
they keep pushing around my little
sister and I told her you can't let them
I played in basketball and this
motivated me to move my whole company
to Chicago so I was telling my dad
I was telling my dad that
um
again I'm just in my backyard guys I'm
just in my backyard so I was telling my
dad that
I was thinking of doing this and my dad
I can't tell if he's excited or not I
don't think he's excited for the randoms
from the show
however I do think my dad likes having
me around and and I do think he wants me
to coach my sister and I get to hang out
with my brother because right now two My
Brothers still live at home my parents
live at home and my youngest sister
lives at home that's five okay now the
other half of the fam
more than half they're all over okay
and then this probably isn't forever but
maybe I love living here guys tell me if
this is a horrible idea but let me show
you what my dad's building so my dad's
building
this compound thing in the backyard
all right it's like a compound
and
see that's the normal house there
this is the compound this is like four
times the size of the normal house
I know why you think I'm coming back
Chicago Winters aren't so bad
so so
hello
good how are you
yeah
yeah I'm moving in here
no
no you just
[Music]
like volleyball there
yeah but
um not that much I'm tired of the rain
I'm tired of the no sun I'm tired of
these British accents I want to come
back to the land of freedom
no I'm coming in here I'm serious my dad
just told me that you maybe he hasn't
told you guys yet you want to see come
here
no I know I'm not coming for another
like six to eight months but my dad said
over there he's gonna build me a studio
in there maybe he hasn't told you guys
yet
okay yeah so okay I'm showing my YouTube
channel too so guys this is the
where we're going to do events and stuff
it's going to be a full basketball court
you guys want to see where my dad said
he's going to put the
all right I'll show you if you want if
you want nope
Okay so
yeah my dad said I can be one of their
first events he was so excited well I
was excited and because when we do a
YouTube show we can put it in here and
then do the seats around you know and
sell tickets and stuff
so then my dad was saying
I told him I wanted to coach my sister's
basketball team
yeah and so he
which one Amelia okay I'm tired of
seeing her get beat up in the paint
yeah yeah it's gotta get a little meaner
yeah so you gotta be a junkyard dog oh
oh yeah oh I I'm gonna I'm gonna beat
her up that's what I was telling her you
can't so my dad so then my dad got this
thing from the barn so I guess he's
gonna put something up there second
floor yeah so guys look
up there
um yeah it's gonna be a second floor
okay here well this is the big water
tank so maybe over it yeah over it okay
yeah so we can do the shows up there
then we do when we do live shows we can
do it in there
said I said I'm moving back
what
yeah that's it yeah that's what my dad
said that that could be used for like
the back room if we wanted to sell
tickets to that or something
yeah
we just got to figure out how to get the
guests out here
but we'll figure it out
what a big van
then she bust them over
oh
well well it's like no but it's like six
days a week we need like seven girls
basically here for the show
yeah yeah I'm just thinking like they
have to be we just got to figure out
where to recruit them from around here
the young ladies I don't know where
they're at because this town has the
largest family is the largest retirement
neighborhood in the Midwest
yeah it's just yeah if you're so it
can't be from here anyways but yeah guys
so this is gonna be the
yeah okay now
sorry guys
now
freaking okay
so yeah
that's what we're gonna do
I'm moving back
for now I'm not saying like it'll be
permanent
but
I was just thinking
Why move away I'm homesick and then I'm
gonna move to another city and be
homesick again
it's just like what's the point of that
so yeah that's um
I probably didn't give you guys the best
of you it doesn't really matter
I'll give you a real tour when we're
back and then I can do like a cooking
show with my mom maybe or
I don't know I have like ideas and [__]
that we could
yeah so and then we could sell events
and tickets and we can rent it out to
other content creators and guys it's
Chicago you guys can just fly in here
we're in the middle of the U.S everyone
can fly in shout out Midwest Midwest
now I'm not saying I won't ever go to
Miami or Nashville
but my dad wants me to coach aau's next
year
now I know I was saying that volleyball
was too much
and now I'm kind of signing up for it
again
but I'm gonna be an assistant coach so
it's kind of like
I'm sorry I'll come when I feel like
coming I'm sorry to the AAU team
foreign
oh wow that's gonna be a lot of work now
that I think about it
I was just thinking
[__] I gotta go to all the games
is this a bad idea no no my sister has
been beat up in the paint we are tired
of being beat up in the paint
yeah but anyways this is also going to
have a bowling alley a shooting range so
you weirdo stay away we got guns
helicons on this compound
because that's what we were worried
about at first we're like well a lot of
people
would see and whatever but we got guns
we got hella guns respectfully okay and
then and then
yeah I'm not gonna lie though my
employees are gonna be so disappointed
where I live is not a hot spot but I
love it like honestly I think the
suburbs are better than is better than
the city I live in the city now and it's
cool there's events but like how many
events are you really going to
I know me it's not that many I'm lame so
it's like I'm gonna take my lame ass in
the suburbs Where I Belong or it's
quieter
I can like walk outside and feel the air
hit me
my family's out here
my siblings are going to get on my
nerves though so is my parents not my
dad
okay even my dad my dad'll try to rope
me into helping build this thing look
I'm sorry Dad I I've helped a little bit
but every time I help him so little help
that they just kick me off
I'm not a builder okay I have skills
yeah I also realized
I'm a baker I have a long way to go in
cooking I'm actually a pretty good Baker
I can make cookies from scratch I can
make brownies from scratch I can make
cake from scratch
am I cooking needs to improve so this
year I'm gonna learn to be like a Master
Chef in the kitchen because my dad was
like well you're messy and I was like
okay Dad that's true
okay I'm not gonna fight him you know
what I mean they know I'm I'm a bit
disorganized okay
however I was like Dad
what if I cook dinner and dessert and he
was like dinner I could take or leave
but your cookies these cookies are fire
yeah but
um you know what's funny I don't even
like the cookies I make the cookies
for my family mostly I like the dough
I'm just the dough type of girl but yeah
um I need to improve on this stuff I'm
trying to get better
but anyways let me let me know what you
guys think of my decision
um subscribe to the channel bring that
notification Bell I'll talk to you next
time